one of my hopes that rise out of those
protests is that there's like a set of
changes that people demand because the
danger is that all of this energy and
heart and spirit and passion ends up
getting channeled but like no one knows
what to do so we need to fight for
something real and concrete that we can
bring to our communities and George
Floyd and his family and say look
George's life and his death brought
about tremendous change and here are the
changes and we can see them all and that
this is a positive turning point in our
nation's history because of your
brother's sacrifice your you know father
sacrifice like the obvious one was like
well you need to arrest the officers and
now they've all been arrested but we can
tell that the protest about something
much much bigger man this is the crisis
of our time in terms of racial justice
and police brutality but there are all
of these things that are layered on top
of it the fact is we've set ourselves up
by having what Cornel West called
failure upon failure upon failure for
decades where you have an economy that
hasn't created a decent way of life for
millions of people and then legal system
and a police system that has not
protected people's rights particularly
people of color and you know one thing I
don't mind being is like the guy who's
still talking about the economy when no
one else is because the economy is still
like underpinning all this stuff like we
have another two million unemployed you
know I mean yeah right now we're adding
fuel to the fire because there's this
backdrop of need and desperation that's
rising we're at depression-era levels of
unemployment yep people are protesting
and rioting on the streets like the
minimum you can do is safeguard people's
material well-being we need to move very
fast on universal basic income because
right now a quarter of the nation's
workforce is out of work I've seen
surveys between 66 and 80 percent of
Americans agree that we should have cash
relief during this time we're going to
be digging out of
this economic catastrophe for years and
we need to start right now and and put
people in position where they feel like
their futures are secure